get ready to see the Backstreet Boys
like you've never seen them before
that's right the boy band stopped by the
Tonight Show and busted out one
seriously a hilarious rendition of their
greatest hit everybody back streets back
with the help of Jimmy Fallon and course
and get this some full-body yellow
chicken soup it is ridiculous you guys
yeah you just need to see this one for
yourself check it out
[Music]
[Music]
so they've dubbed this the box street
boys it's a good job with a buck really
I feel like it's really fitting for this
of course as usual Jimmy Fallon Slade
what he brings it every time on his show
he really does he always has fun with
his guests I love that the Backstreet
Boys aren't really taking themselves
that seriously and I think I'm into it
I'm here for it I think they get some
cool dad points for this one I did see
oh okay well thankfully for fans of the
group the guys return to the stage later
sans chicken suits to sing their newest
single chances
[Music]
the singers were promoting their new
album DNA which dropped on Thursday
night posting to Instagram quote we have
been a group for more than 25 years and
this is our favorite album ever listen
watch share after 10 years we we have
very different eclectic tastes between
all of us that kind of when we think
when we put them in the lab and we put
them all together it creates the
Backstreet Boy sound after over two
decades together a few more things have
changed for the 90s heartthrobs the boys
are bringing their families with them on
a world tour cute
now that we're older we have our kids
with us you know hopefully they're gonna
be able to come out during the summer
legs because they'll be out of school I
love having the kids on the road
especially in Europe because they're
getting a world history lesson okay one
thing I'm seriously hoping for and I
know you are too cuz you said it we want
these guys to vlog well yes family on
tour
we need a behind the scenes look we want
to see the kids do they know the
throwback Backstreet Boys moves I mean I
just want to see it all and one thing's
for sure they do have a much more mature
sound so it'll be nice to see that on
the world tour as well so cute do it
guys and of course 2019 is gonna be a
really big year for these guys they'll
be returning to their larger-than-life
Las Vegas residency in February and they
kick off their DNA world tour in May yes
and while the Backstreet Boys are
stronger than ever now they recently
opened up about the struggles they faced
in their early days as a band 25 years
that's huge but there's still so much
left that we haven't accomplished that
we haven't done to be able to have like
this
I don't even know what better way to put
it in second chance we need to know what
each person's breaking point is which I
think we know now well one thing is for
sure they are not the only ones who are
happy about this second chance they have
clearly stood the test of time and you
can count on us to bring you all the
latest bsv news as it comes our way so
be sure to subscribe to all things ET as
usual I'm at Kourtney underscore teza
know and I'm at Holley underscore Steven
bye for now
[Music]